Mr President
you are the oldest president ever pretty
good shape huh which leads to my next
question you are more aware of this than
anyone
some people ask whether you are fit for
the job and when you hear that I wonder
what you think
watch me
that old expression the proof of the put
is in the eating
how you doing people I'm Dave Rubin it's
September 9th
2022 we're live streaming on the rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV share subscribe tap
the notification bell all that good
stuff and the cold open today was just a
little excerpt we're going to play
plenty more of uh the elderly man in
wonderful shape Joe Biden who's
pretending to be president he did a
really fluffy interview on 60 Minutes
which you know they obviously edit these
interviews and if 60 Minutes Or CBS or
any of these organizations wanted to be
honest it's not that there's anything
necessarily wrong with editing but
perhaps they should say you know we did
an interview for say 40 minutes we had
to edit out 20 minutes of it or how many
times we had to stop because it was just
a lot of mumbled nonsense some of it
made sense which shows that they
obviously were editing he already said a
couple things in the interview that
they've had to walk back the official
White House has had to move on a couple
things sort of the one of them being
maybe sending troops across the world
for something that nobody wants to get
involved in anyway big mess hope you had
a great weekend I'm feeling good uh
today's show is going to be an extension
of sort of what we were doing last week
because as you know my theme lately
really has been that we can't just uh
expose hypocrisy we can't just mock them
they are not going to stop it's Gonna
Keep moving nonsense whether it's gender
stuff or race stuff or covid stuff or
climate lockdowns it's just going to
keep coming so what can we do we have to
acknowledge the stuff and yes we can
mock it and all that but that can't be
the only thing that we're doing what we
need to be doing is really standing up
straight perhaps with our shoulders back
and telling the world sort of what we
believe why we believe it and why it's
important now to fight for these things
and perhaps more important than anything
else to widen the tent of sane people
right because it's basically roughly
saying people versus woke maniacs and
the corporations behind them I think
there's more of us we've just been
confused by algorithms and culture wars
and all of that stuff so Jordan Peterson
actually he wrote he's been working on
this I think for many many years
actually and I've seen draft of it over
the years he has finally released a new
conservative Manifesto that addresses so
many of the things that I've been
talking about so that's how we're going
to frame the show today we're going to
show you a little bit of it up top and
at the end and then some will compare
and contrast what Jordan's talking about
with some of the things that are going
on in the world including the people of
Martha's Vineyard the good tolerant
liberals of Martha's Vineyard who called
in the Army and had those 50 migrants
booted in the name of diversity anyway
before we get to any of that let me talk
to you about real estate agents I trust
you guys know that buying or selling a
home is already one of the most
stressful things you can do and it can
be 10 times worse if you're not working
with the right agent generally speaking
our homes are our biggest investment
which is a ton of responsibility and you
need an agent who takes that seriously
and that's exactly why I recommend real
estate agents I trust they work with
only the best agents in every Market
they do their homework talking to every
agent before inviting them to join their
Network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents the their team
makes the introduction then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records they're the best sellers in
their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just head over to real estate
agentsitrust.com today provide them with
some basic info they'll contact you to
make an introduction to an agent in your
town you move to Florida you live
happily ever after Okay so let's get
right to it we cannot just be fighting
against bad ideas all the time we need
to actually clearly and cleanly state
what we are for
Jordan Peterson has posted a 40-minute
video reading a new conservative
Manifesto that he has been working on
for many many years and he has finally
released it gonna play about a minute
and a half of it uh right now hello
everyone
I'm going to read to you today something
I've been working on well for many
decades I would say really but more
intensely and specifically in the last
four months I've reviewed it with a lot
of people around the world I it's called
a conservative Manifesto and it's an
attempt to
begin the process of outlining a
positive vision for the future on the
center right and classic liberal front
it's not designed to be propaganda tool
it's designed to be a an invitation
let's say a profound crisis of meaning
currently afflicts destabilizes and
demoralizes
The Sovereign citizens of the West and
the social institutions upon which we
depend what are the values of Paramount
importance to the conservative
temperament
currently crying out for rediscovery
reconsideration and discussion
an inevitably incomplete but crucially
necessary list might include
humility
Liberty
autonomy truth
agency
identity
Merit responsibility tradition
community
stewardship
Justice
and unity
okay so that is just a small bite of
what Jordan lays out he gets into it
much more extensively I highly recommend
you guys check out the full 38 minute
video and we have a little uh snippet
more coming up in just a bit but in
essence what he is saying here is hey if
the world the West is going to continue
it is going to be a sort of center right
we can say conservative classical
liberal Alliance that will create this
big tent and what are the things that
we'll be fighting for well they put up a
couple words right there some of them
truth honesty reality humility Liberty
autonomy Merit responsibility all the
things that we know are the right things
right and if you do those things right
then maybe you get to a little bit of
unity what we're used to being
told is half the country's evil now
unite now let's heal but they always
mean heal the other way heal meaning bow
so how do we actually do this and what
does a what does a movement look like
well we have to fight the bad ideas and
then we have to find the political
people that are doing the right thing so
now let's take it to sort of where we're
at in America at this moment and as you
know there there was this insane
absolutely insane Martha's Vineyard uh
event the last couple days which all in
essence it was was Ron DeSantis doing
exactly what he said he was going to do
doing what was in the budget that the
Democrats in Florida signed on for and
then of course the media went absolutely
crazy because when migrants or illegal
immigrants whatever you want to call
them when they show up to Rich liberal
towns this is very very bad news but
when they're over running you know say
poor border towns in Texas it's okay so
what do the Democrats General really do
when when we're talking about truth
honesty reality humility Liberty
autonomy Merit what do they usually do
well they scare you by telling you that
the other people are really evil here's
an interview with Bill Clinton this
weekend on what he thinks is going to
happen over the next couple months
could Biden break the historical pattern
of the you know midterms going back
absolutely
but we could hold both these houses
but we have to say the right things
and we have to note the Republicans
always close well why because they find
some new way to scare The Living
Daylights out of Swing voters
about something that's what they did in
2021 where they made critical race
Theory sound worse than smallpox
and it wasn't being taught in any public
schools in America but they didn't care
they just
all right so there's Bill Clinton lying
and scaring people so he's saying oh the
Republicans try to scare people and then
it's exactly what he did and of course
he's lying because critical race theory
is being taught in elementary schools
middle schools high schools and
certainly colleges throughout the
country they often use weird language
around it so it doesn't sound like
exactly like textbook racist a textbook
critical race Theory but it is critical
race Theory Equity all of these bad
ideas have been pushed into the American
education system we all know it this is
why thankfully all of these parents are
now showing up to these school board
meetings and getting involved and
pushing back this is what led to Glenn
junkin's election in Virginia so Bill
Clinton's lying he's and he's trying to
scare other people right he's trying to
scare the other he's saying oh well the
Republicans are mean and they scare
people they look what they did with
critical race Theory and it's like well
wait a minute actually that was the
right thing they were fighting for their
children to not be brainwashed washed
that is what they do that is what you
would want to do as a parent I should
say so it's it's complete nonsense and
it speaks to the volumes of
unfortunately what modern liberalism
progressives have to offer to Americans
there's there's pretty much nothing
there other than making you scared as
opposed to
honesty Liberty value hard work all of
those things so here's another concrete
example of it on CNBC over the weekend
our gay Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge and again I only mention
that he's gay because it's the only
reason he got the job he's not very good
at the job he took a couple of months
off right when he got the job we've had
this crazy uh all of these
transportation problems we know if his
job is roughly related to gas prices and
things like that supply chain issues etc
etc so he goes on CNBC and the host just
was not having his nonsense he looked
really tone deaf I mean what you're
telling me so just stick to the script
the economy is great the border is
secure our cities are safe
about the soup that we're in right now
and and we can all try to deal with it
together instead of just nobody's saying
that our nobody's saying we don't have
any problems okay so that's a fine job
by the CNBC host because Pete is just on
there going oh basically everything's
okay and then at the end when he's
pushed out well no it's saying there
aren't any problems but there are
massive problems and we all know it and
it's because of all of the nonsensical
policies that you people have pushed in
like critical race Theory and wokeness
the thing that Bill Clinton is
pretending doesn't exist and is not real
and all of those things so now let's
move this to uh Joe Biden's interview on
60 Minutes first off he made a very
important point that politics has just
gotten very very dirty by some people
being very mean
which we do today think about it it's
all personal tax it's about motive it's
not about I disagreeing on the on the
subject matter well that's interesting
Joe because I have a vague recollection
of this very scary speech from two weeks
ago
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
so do you see what they do I always tell
you this is by Design on one hand
they'll say oh we're for Unity we're for
diversity and healing and all of these
things and it's gotten too personal okay
and then on the other hand they'll give
a speech a minute later or in that case
it was right you know two weeks ago
where they do exactly what they accuse
the rest of us doing was that Joe Biden
saying anything about the ideas of Maga
or of Donald Trump no is it just
attacking the people it was just a
baseless those are the bad guys those 74
million people well what are you gonna
do with those people Joe Biden uh and
then Joe really stepped in it so this is
this is probably the worst moment he had
a couple sort of somewhat befuddled
moments but overall you know they had
his face freshly botoxed and his hair
plugs were good and the makeup was right
and his eyeball didn't explode overall
it was pretty decent the packaging of
the whole thing but he did have one
major major gaffe when asked about China
and Taiwan but U.S forces defend the
island yes if in fact there was an
unprecedented attack after our interview
a White House official told us U.S
policy has not changed officially the
U.S will not say whether American forces
would defend Taiwan but the
commander-in-chief had a view of his own
so unlike Ukraine to be clear sir U.S
forces U.S men and women would defend
Taiwan in the event of a Chinese
Invasion yeah there was something kind
of funny there if you're just like an
Insider TV person how quickly the edit
there from Biden basically saying yeah
troops to oh but the White House is
saying no way
so this is just him saying something
either without knowing what he's saying
or what our policy is or anything else
it's also a crazy thing to say that if
China was to invade Taiwan which I would
not be for and let me be 100 clear I
believe that Taiwan is an independent
Nation every independent nation has a
right to Define its borders and defend
its borders as it sees fit and we should
be allies with Taiwan and all of those
things he's saying we're going to send
troops I mean troops those are soldiers
those are human lives of Americans to
fight what does he mean to fight on the
ground in Taiwan against China halfway
across the world it's just a crazy
proposition now you could say uh if
China invaded Taiwan or tried to Annex
Taiwan or whatever it is that we would
maybe sanction them putting aside the
validity of sanctions or anything else
we could sanction them we could try to
do something in the U.N we could maybe
arm the Taiwanese but we're going to
send troops there it's just a it's just
an insane thing it's also an insane
thing because in light of what's going
on with Ukraine where we're in a war but
we're not in a war we're funding the war
we're you know giving endless dollars
for the war we're giving weapons but we
haven't declared war there's no debate
about war it's just like more nonsense
so immediately obviously the
administration had to walk that one back
but now let me link that to where we
started here which is that I believe at
this point we basically have like a
completely insane side on virtually
every issue whether it's immigration
whether it's China whether it's covid
whatever it might be and then there's
another side trying to put together
something sane that's what Jordan's
trying to lay out here and notice he
didn't say by the way he didn't say this
is a republican Manifesto It's a
conservative Manifesto I mean it's not a
political party platform it is a set of
ideas that that if we can hopefully come
around to that maybe we can defend the
basic ideas of the West which in a
conservative Manifesto he's defining as
classically liberal ideas that's a whole
other topic I wrote a book about it a
couple years back okay so what's
happening here is that we're seeing and
why a lot of people think that there's
going to be this this Red Wave despite
what Bill Clinton is trying to scare
people into we're seeing this
conservative movement expand not only
because of the demo Democratic rhetoric
but the policy right it's both things
their rhetoric is to scare the hell out
of you and their policies are basically
uh nonsensical and they're being exposed
as such so this DeSantis story and what
happened related to Flying 50 people
to Martha's Vineyard which DeSantis said
he was going to do
he got the money in his budget the
Democrats in the state senate voted for
it okay now they're all calling him
racist on the very same thing that they
voted for uh it's exposing hypocrisy at
the most extraordinary levels as I said
on Friday this is like one of the best
red pill moments it's such a great story
because it's showing how inept all of
these people are so here is our black
lesbian press secretary Karin
Jean-Pierre getting called out at the
White House for doing the same thing
that the Sanders did this is apparently
me
you know he said it was essentially
no different than what the federal
government has done in sending you know
flights in the middle of the night
that's where it's characterized it uh
you know taking migrants to various
different states two versions of them
so we are offering Solutions that's what
the Biden Harris Administration has been
doing since day one
God she's incredible like it's not I
don't know what questions she's
answering it doesn't matter she just has
a we offering Solutions it's sort of
like Kamala remember the video we showed
you last week is the border secure every
nation has a border they just answer
questions that have nothing to do with
nothing they say words to get to the
period in the sentence so the sentence
is over and they've done nothing but
take you on a ride of BS so of course
what they're referring to there is that
the federal government we know this has
put migrants on planes when they cross
over the border and then sent them all
over the country we know so de Santa
said hey I'm just doing the same thing
that they've been doing and she has no
response to that of course and then you
get all these clowns that are trying to
figure out a way to just to sue DeSantis
and everything else but again if you
just look at the reality whether whether
you think it's a political Ploy whether
you don't like the tone of any of this
or if you think it's just mutually
assured destruction
what what is next to all of that is one
guy did exactly what he said he was
going to do and then one guy Biden
didn't do what he said he was going to
do because they say that there's a
border but now these people are pouring
in so there obviously isn't a safe
border and then you have these crazy
Democrats with their idea of sanctuary
cities and Martha's Vineyard they had a
big thing at Town Hall about nobody's
illegal and everything else and then
when 50 people showed up they get 150
National Guard and they boot them in 24
hours it's rather extraordinary but the
idea of sanctuary cities of saying hey
we're a city where if you're illegal
meaning you're a Criminal by default
you've come into this country illegally
you are not supposed to be here you are
a criminal uh you can stay here you can
stay here you can work here you can get
benefits here we'll give you covid shots
everything else
Democrats seem to be for this and even
now
they're for it here's New York city
mayor Eric Adams just over a year ago
you tweeted quote New York City will
remain a sanctuary city under an ad
Adams Administration what is your
message to migrants arriving in the U.S
should they still come to New York City
well I think that they should come to
any place in the country that they
desire of their pursuit of the American
dream
I don't know how that man got the job
well I guess I do know because people
were so fed up with that ridiculous Bill
de Blasio who was openly a socialist and
a communist and then there were all
these people there that thought oh Eric
Adams will be a little bit better a
little bit better
um Eric Adams that in some ways that
almost is an impeachable statement when
you are an elected official
it is your job to defend the laws
whether you're the president of the
United States you have to defend the
federal laws you have to abide by the
Constitution if you're the mayor there
are laws in the city of New York that
you have to abide by you can't just say
okay yeah you can come and the fact that
he's so tone deaf so you know what I say
more then in that case uh Governor
DeSantis if you're watching this or
Governor Abbott in Texas if you're
watching this keep sending them to New
York the mayor just said that he wants
them so let's just exacerbate the
situation I don't mean that sort of to
be a dick I mean that because we have to
get this to its end it has to get to its
volition where Democrat cities will be
exactly what they say that they want and
Republican cities and states will be
lawful there will be they will be clean
and pleasant and have flourishing
economies and they will be safe and
everything else oh and get this one this
is just an Incredible video I cannot
believe that they didn't blow up the m
MSNBC truck as this was broadcasting
here is an MSNBC reporter talking about
how actually the people showing up to
Martha's Vineyard they like the santis
now I can't tell you they are not angry
at Ron DeSantis they're actually
thanking him for having brought them to
Martha's Vineyard where they were they
were very well received but other people
well they're saying they're being used
as political pawns they don't resent it
for now and they know they're the lucky
ones okay so these 50 people they show a
bit more at this Vineyard Martha's
vineyard's a lovely place and apparently
it has all these nice tolerant decent
people some of them even bake them cakes
and things and then they booted them
within 24 hours and they got those 150
soldiers there and everything else and
they probably took down their you know
no human is illegal sign from there from
their lawn but the point is that these
people were not abused in any way the if
you want to talk about the abuse of
these people the abuse of these people
is an Administration that sends signals
that you can come to our border get in
our country and then our mayors that say
yes come here those Mayors like Eric
Adams not only is Eric Adams abusing the
the illegal immigrants right he's
abusing them because the city cannot
sustain them right we know this and
Muriel Bowser in DC the city is running
out of beds and homeless shelters
because of all the illegals but then
you're abusing your own citizens your
own citizens who have a right to your
city services who have a right to clean
streets and to have a right to be able
to walk down the street and not be
attacked or raped or anything else
anyway despite the fact that this one is
just so obviously DeSantis doing the
right thing and the Democrats and the
media just melting down because if they
didn't melt down they'd have to say oh
Biden screwed up the Border these
Democrat policies don't work so they
have to keep ramping it up that's what
they have to do so now evil devil
worshiper Gavin Newsom who is the
governor
of California oh and I'll put the money
in the jar we will get someone out of
Cali and get them to the free state of
Florida soon enough
um he's trying to get in on this now
Gavin Newsom let's remember 350
000 people fled California in 2021. I
got two others in the room right now I
moved two companies out of California in
2021. in 2020 was the first year ever
that California had a net loss in
population then it happened again in 21.
Gavin Newsom is the worst governor in
the country he loves high taxes he loves
big government he loves not following
his own rules he's just he's just
patently slimy and evil so how do you
think I feel about him anyway he tweeted
this what govern DeSantis and Greg
Abbott Texas are doing isn't clever it's
cruel I'm formerly requesting the
Department of Justice begin an immediate
investigation into these inhumane
efforts to use kids as political pawns
now I went highbrow on this one I
responded to Gavin with this yeah I
found that picture of him online I just
think it's perfect he's a lizard with a
fake face there is something he's just
evil that's the point guys he's just
absolutely evil but the point is
DeSantis did nothing illegal they will
probably try to investigate him now like
this is just what the machine does he
just did what he said he was going to do
if if you're looking for blame anywhere
again I just have to beat this one into
your head so that if you get into a
debate with your friends about this
there's only one way the blame goes here
the blame is not over who Moved people
out of their states once the people are
here the blame goes to the people that
let these people in and that is the
Biden Administration anyway as usual
DeSantis isn't just taking it from Gavin
Newsom he's given it back so the
governor of California
sent a letter to the Department of
Justice saying you need to prosecute
Texas and Florida Governors and all I
can say is um I think his hair gel is
interfering with his brain function
I make fun of somebody with too much
hair gel the amount of spray I'm using
around here anyway the point is DeSantis
is just going to keep fighting and
that's what we've needed that's what
we've asked for and again to link this
to the beginning of the show that's what
a new let's say conservative ethos would
be we do the right thing we don't bow we
fight back we punch back all of those
things okay so that's that's really
really beautiful so what are they going
to do well you may remember last week we
did a whole expose on this New York
Times magazine piece on Ron DeSantis can
we pull up the image so this was the New
York Times magazine last week and the
headline there on the Tweet is Ron
DeSantis the Republican party's future
in New York Times mag Matt whatever
conducts an extensive examination of the
life and record of the Florida governor
and you can see by the image there what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to create a fight between Trump and
DeSantis right they want Trump to see
that and be like oh no the media is
going to him I'm going to attack him and
there's nothing that would make the
herbs them happier more because if there
could be a massive split
in the Republican Party well then what
would that be it would lead to actually
what Bill Clinton was talking about
there that the Democrats could actually
hold the senate in the house so that's
what they want now last week you may
remember what I said about that there
was that what their move is going to be
is not only that they're going to try to
create this fight between Trump and
DeSantis but the line will be and I am
just so convinced of this the line will
be that Ron DeSantis is actually worse
than Donald Trump because he'll have all
the Trump policies but he's effective
he's a manager he's not a buffoon he
doesn't fire at the hip he's calculating
so he's going to be he's going to be
Hitler on steroids basically is the move
that the media is going to make and then
like clockwork how about this op-ed
yesterday in the New York Times Ron
DeSantis may be more competent in Trump
in terms of his ability to use the
levers of state to amass power but he's
also meaner and more rigid without the
soft edges and eccentricity of the
actual Donald Trump writes whoever okay
so do you see do you see Trump was soft
Trump had these soft edges and he was
eccentric now they're going to make
Trump a hero in the name of trying to
take out DeSantis just know it guys
just absolutely know what they are going
to do and once you know it they have no
power over you once you realize what the
media is they have no power over you
their bad policies their lies none of it
none of it will work so now let's get
back to the beginning of where we
started today we'll go full circle on
you Jordan Peterson on his conservative
Manifesto okay how can this thing
succeed how do we fight it how do we
handle the left well here's Jordan A
house divided against itself
cannot stand
respect for individual sovereignty and
courageous trust in the essential
Goodwill of others means unity in both
appearance and reality conservatives at
their best are characterized by profound
appreciation for the necessity of such
Unity apprehending it properly
as the basis for the peaceful
cooperation and competition that made
makes and keeps us strong
in the face of both adversity and enmity
the demoralized people of the West and
indeed in the rest of the world are
therefore crying out
for the restoration of the abdicated
values of individual sovereignty
and responsible genuine social service
and purpose
whose acceptance and embodiment make our
free societies possible productive
admirable generative
and stable
conservatives who abide by the dictates
of the Eternal Western Canon
have the opportunity beckoning in front
of them
to once again make the case
that the principles upon which we
operate the virtues in which we believe
and the freedom we have been divinely
granted
truly and eternally constitute the basis
for the life more abundant which people
of good faith desire
and which we have every ability
to establish and maintain
guys I think the point of today's show
because I have no doubt that as you're
watching that Jordan video you're
feeling the same thing I'm feeling is
there are other people who want to take
life seriously there are other people
who want to fix this thing there are
other people who want to get past the
madness uh get past all of the craziness
that that we are confronted with on a
daily basis and what Jordan is saying
there is that wide tent that thing if we
want to get to that to that Unity what
does he always bring it back to the
sovereignty of the individual that it
will start with you it will start with
you and your family and your community
everything else and it might seem a
little odd that a Canadian academic a
Canadian psychology Professor would be
sort of the leading voice on what a new
conservative movement would look like it
might be a little odd that a former
Progressive Lefty liberal from New York
who is married to a dude and has a kid
might be one of the people really
pushing the idea for this new
conservative movement but that right
there is why it can work because we're
all different and we all have some
uneven things about us we all have
different ideas and don't fit perfectly
into boxes and how can we take a bunch
of people all of us all of you guys who
I know my audience doesn't agree on
everything and that's why I love it it's
like how can we take all of us and say
but there are things that we won't trade
we won't trade all the hard-fought
victories of the past we won't trade all
of the things that we once knew to be
true for a whole bunch of new nonsense
uh that we're that what you say and what
you do actually matters that's the plan
I think we could do it I really do think
we can do it and uh well I have nothing
better to do than save the world do you
uh guys it's me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community this
is the one I put up I thought this was
pretty there were so many good memes in
the last couple days take this hot meal
and gtf out of Martha's Vineyard just
perfect couple hundred people have
already jumped in with their own memes
of the day again that's
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
play along and let's get to a couple
comments uh Chuck says every time a
Democrat makes a statement it is like
watching a clan member in a full outfit
pointing out and calling someone racist
the hypocrisy is so blatant it is just
funny now look I know it I know it you
know it I think they know it I think
they know we know and all of that stuff
but we just have to keep going and
that's by the way when they say sane
things you know every now and again when
Jake Tapper says something saying or
someone else on CNN says something say
more in the very rare moments that a
Democrat official says something saying
or when Bill Maher says something saying
it's why I bring it up right because
it's like okay then we should foster
those good ideas maybe you guys still
aren't getting to the conclusion but
like let's let's see if there's anything
saying here now you know my position on
this right if you want to be sane We
have basically the sanity party and duh
party that's kind of where we're at at
this point in in but those are those are
political parties not sort of the the
set of ideas uh that are more important
than just whether you vote democrat or
republican but yeah they just lie about
absolutely everything man they lie about
everything uh okay EK says they are
blatantly lying and expecting everyone
to just go along with it it's getting to
the point where it can't be uh accepted
as reality though right that's the
problem
I was thinking about it this morning
actually when we were trying to frame
the show it's like the endless debunking
of Lies it takes work and that's why I'm
saying we can't just do that because if
if all we do is just oh you see they
lied about this one and they were the
ones questioning elections then and they
claimed Russian interfered and Bill
Clinton raped this one and like if we
just debunk their lies and their
hypocrisies we'll always just be sliding
off into the abyss with them so we must
build something separate that's what
Jordan's talking about in this new
conservative Manifesto it's what I'm
trying to do and speaking of things that
I'm trying to do and building and all
that uh one thing that's actually very
very cool is that Rumble is now a public
company I believe it is as of today if
I'm not mistaken
um so you you know I I'm very excited
that there's that Free Speech has gone
public let's put it that way pretty good
so that's uh that's spectacular uh by
the way my week is a little nutty this
week because I am going
Phoenix is looking at me right now he's
freaking out he's coming with me we're
going to Los Angeles tomorrow we will
have a live show and then in the
afternoon we are going to Los Angeles
because on Wednesday I am doing Bill
Maher's podcast we're going to sit down
at his house for an hour and a half two
hours and we're gonna shoot the [ __ ] we
will see what happens uh and then I
gotta jump on a plane immediately
because on Thursday morning I'm dinging
the bell I am going to NASDAQ and I'm
dinging the bell with the rumble people
very cool very cool you know I had this
idea for locals years ago we built it we
got investors we did something of value
we merged with Rumble and and free
speech is going public it's just as
simple as that we got a chance guys uh
reminder my full interview with Vivek
ramaswami is up across platforms right
now uh ad for you as always at
reubenreport.locals.com and uh well
we've got a cold Close For You Joe Bud
watch me if you think I don't have the
energy level of mental acuity the best
way to get something done if you if it
holds near and dear to you that you like
to be able to
anyway from from uh excuse me from
Charlotte one and another line going
from in Florida down to Tampa of Putin's
cryptography yeah
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
the idea that um
Los Angeles and uh and uh um uh
um what am I doing here for two reasons
one
two
because we haven't been able to
communicate it in a way that is uh um
Mike may say another way but the nature
not
a solid meeting
with um with uh
the uh they make a very good point
here's the deal
here's what drives the driver in the
states
that are affected here's what that you
can do the drivers the um